Speaker 1: A stunning new poll shows Trump's
support among Republicans collapsing to historic
lows. You have to see this. It doesn't bode
well for Trump and it does start to point to
will this guy even make it to the first Republican
primaries? USA Today reports via Yahoo News. Trump
in trouble. Republican support for his 2024 bid
falls amid political and legal setbacks. This is
a USA Today Suffolk University poll, and it finds
that by a 2 to 1 margin, Republican and Republican
leaning voters say they want Trump's policies,
but they want someone other than Trump to be the
nominee. 31% of Republicans want Trump to run. 61%
of Republicans believe it should be a different
Republican nominee, mostly to continue Trump's
policies. Which is funny because it's like what
policies? He did nothing other than putting in
place some confused tariffs. They have a name in
mind, writes USA Today. Two thirds of Republicans
and those inclined to vote Republican want
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis to run for president
by double digits, 56 to 33. They prefer DeSantis
over Trump. These are stunning numbers. I
know people will write to me and say, David,
they're only calling landlines. No. Suffolk USA
Today uses cell phones as well. Well, but David,
think about who would even answer a phone call
from a pollster. Okay. Yes. A lot of people don't
answer their phone, but I don't know that the
people who answer are disproportionately likely
to be DeSantis supporters. I mean, it seems that
this is a fair poll that was done as correctly as
any poll would be done. So this is a red flag for
Donald Trump. And the question continues to be,
can Trump make it to the primaries or is support
going to crater to such a degree that he's going
to bail to avoid a further humiliation and cite
health reasons or some other thing that he wants
to do? We don't know the answer. It's very early,
but the early numbers are looking good. We'll talk
more about campaign events which are starting
to be put on the calendar sometime soon. We're
going to take a quick break. All the clips I
played for you today will be on our Instagram,
which you can find it David Pakman show. And of
course they will all be on our YouTube channel.
Subscribe on YouTube. Okay. Three. I just got the
November numbers. 3.4 million people in November
watched our clips but aren't subscribed.
If we can get just a third of those 3.4
million people overnight, we get to 2 million
YouTube subscribers. Make it happen, my friends.